На тлі скандалу довкола нардепа Михайла Добкіна
знову спалахнула дискусія про зняття депутатської недоторканності.
Дебати про це ведуться в Україні ще з часів Кучми.
Про необхідність позбавлення обранців імунітету
заявляли чи не всі українські президенти.
От і Порошенко нещодавно згадав
… такий анахронізм, як депутатська недоторканність
Тим часом депутатська недоторканність є в усіх європейських країнах,
зокрема і в Німеччині.
Але тут таких пристастей, як в Україні, довкола неї не вирує.
Депутатський імунітет мають усі члени Бундестагу.
Це право їм гарантує Конституція ФРН.
Недоторканність обмежена терміном дії депутатських повноважень
і може бути скасована за рішенням парламенту.
Однак якщо в Україні її часто використовують як особистий привілей,
щоб, наприклад, уникнути покарання за махінації чи інші злочини,
то німецьких обранців, серед яких немає великих бізнесменів чи олігархів,
імунітет захищає від переслідування за політичними мотивами.
Аби притягти обрАнця до відповідальності або заарештувати,
правоохоронці мають отримати на це згоду Бундестагу.
Проте якщо депутата затримали під час скоєння злочину
або на наступний день після нього,
згода парламенту на його арешт не потрібна.
В історії німецького парламенту не раз траплялися випадки позбавлення імунітету.
Останній приклад - рік тому,
скандал із членом фракції "Зелених" Фолькером Беком.
Його позбавили депутатського імунітету
через півграма метамфетаміну, знайденого в нього.
Претензії до депутатів можуть бути різними:
від перевищення швидкості до корупції.
Сумнівів у тому, що порушників зрештою позбавлять недоторканності
а притягнуть до відповідальності, у Німеччині ні у кого немає
ані у парламентарів, ані у їхніх виборців.
Тож якщо порівнювати із закидами на адресу українських народних обранців,
проступки їхніх німецьких колег - дріб'язок.
І недоторканність для них - це не спосіб уникнути кримінальної відповідальності,
а демократичний інструмент захисту від політичного тиску.